[Música]
en la tercera noche de la convención
nacional demócrata en eeuu la senadora
kamala harris aceptó la nominación como
fórmula vicepresidencial de joe biden
para las elecciones del 3 de noviembre
hillary clinton y barack obama
describieron a donald trump como una
amenaza para la democracia tenemos
reporte desde nueva york
el opositor ruso alexéi navalni está
inconsciente en una unidad de cuidados
intensivos de la ciudad de homs que su
portavoz denuncia que fue envenenado
hipótesis de que aún está por
confirmarse navalny es uno de los más
fervientes críticos de vladimir putin
abogado de 44 años que ya ha estado
varias veces en prisión o por sus
posturas
y lisboa es el centro de atención para
los fanáticos del fútbol este domingo se
disputa la gran final de la champions
entre el parís saint germain y el bayern
munich que derrotó 3 a 0 al olympique de
lyon la capital portuguesa acoge este
torneo con la presencia de los mejores
clubes europeos y aprovecha para una
necesaria reactivación del turismo
comienza la mañana y también las
noticias en france 24 mi nombre es
ángela gómez y aquí comenzamos en eeuu
se realizó la tercera y penúltima noche
de la convención del partido demócrata
con kamala harris como principal
protagonista la senadora aceptó
oficialmente la nominación como
aspirante a la vicepresidencia en dupla
con joe biden es la primera mujer negra
y estadounidense de origen asiático que
se postula para el segundo cargo más
importante del país por un gran partido
peter podemos hacerlo mejor y merecemos
mucho más fuera
we must debemos elegir a un presidente
que nos ofrezca algo diferente algo
mejor en tu día
y que haga el trabajo importante un
presidente que nos una a todos negros
blancos latinos asiáticos indígenas para
conseguir el futuro que queremos
colectivamente active we want sólo una
figura logró robar más protagonismo el
ex presidente barack obama quien
prescindió de las cortesías hacia el
presidente candidato donald trump y lo
describió como una amenaza
nunca esperé que mi sucesor a adoptar a
mi visión no continuará con mis
políticas
si esperaba por el bien de mi país que
donald trump mostrará algo de interés en
tomarse el sitio y trabajo
primer cambio que llegara a sentir el
peso del despacho y encontrará algo de
reverencia por la democracia que se
ponía bajo su cuidado pero nunca lo hizo
brindar verdad en la ciudad de nueva
york está nuestra corresponsal
mamen sala buen día para usted mamen y
le pregunto cámara harris y su historia
se convirtió ya en la primera
afroamericana y de ascendencia asiática
que asume una candidatura
vicepresidencial por un gran partido del
país háblenos de la jornada de ayer
sí muy buenos días pues sin duda ese fue
el momento más importante de toda la
jornada cuando cama la carreta acepto
esa nominación y en su discurso dijo
estar preparada y 100 también destacó la
importancia de luchar contra el racismo
para el que esté un tipo no existe
vacuna los temas de ayer fueron mucho
más sociales de lo que vimos en las
jornadas anteriores se habló sobre el
control del uso de armas y para ello
éste invitó a una de las supervivientes
en la matanza de la matanza de portland
se habló también de la cuestión de
inmigración no solamente por parte de
los oradores políticos que participaron
en estas dos horas de discursos sino
también con personas que lo han vivido
en primera persona que contaron sus
tragedias como una niña de 11 años que
perdió a su madre cuando fue deportada a
méxico la historia de miles de
inmigrantes en este país coincidiendo
con el centenario de que se celebraba
precisamente esta semana que las mujeres
apostó día votar en eeuu escuchamos
también una defensa de los derechos de
la mujer de la mano de la presidenta de
la cámara de representantes nancy pelosi
quien destacó él
incorrecto dijo de tonal trabaje a las
mujeres dijo que ella misma lo había
vivido en primera persona escuchamos
también a la ex candidata para el 2016
hillary clinton quien destacó la
importancia de ir a votar y lo hizo
poniéndose ella mismo como ejemplo
disfrutado en 2016 ganó el voto popular
pero no llevó a la presidencia sin duda
otro de los momentos destacados ya lo
comentaba esfuerzo un foto del ex
presidente barack obama que dijo que
bueno que esperaba algo más del actual
presidente dijo que esperaba que tratara
de a su labor en el despacho oval como
algo más que un reality show
hoy es la última noche la más importante
el gran cierre de la convención
demócrata cuáles serán los platos
fuertes
pues sin duda el momento más importante
va a ser cuando el candidato yo bailé en
acepte su nominación y efectos turístico
desde delaware un discurso que irá en la
línea de puesto lo que puede hacer el
depor este país en los próximos cuatro
años mantener la unidad y sacar a eeuu
del caos y la crisis en la que se vive
en este momento según ha contado el
partido escucharemos también a figuras
destacadas dentro del partido demócrata
a candidato que pelearon con él por efe
en estas primarias como el alcalde
pitbull tiny o el senador por y brujas
como la escal de las arcas de la ciudad
de nueva york michael bloomberg va a ser
una jornada muy interesante en la que
donald trump ya ha anunciado que estará
haciendo campaña en pensilvania muy
cerca del pueblecito donde nació el
candidato demócrata iovine y además dijo
que seguramente entrará por teléfono
para realizar una entrevista con la
cadena fox coincidiendo con el último
día de esta jornada de cuatro días por
una convención de bogotá gracias a usted
mamey seguimos con más noticias vamos a
cambiar de tema y vamos hasta rusia
el líder opositor alexéi navalni está
hospitalizado en cuidados
si vos en la ciudad de homs con sospecha
de envenenamiento naval y está
inconsciente y conectado a un respirador
artificial se sintió enfermo cuando
viajaba desde la ciudad siberiana de
tomsk rumbo a moscú y su avión tuvo que
aterrizar de emergencia la teoría de su
envenenamiento aún no ha sido confirmada
por los médicos que lo atienden el
opositor es una de las figuras más
visibles contra el gobierno de vladímir
putin él dijo que se sentía muy mal y me
pidió un pañuelo ya que estaba sudando
me pidió que hablara con él porque
quería concentrarse en el sonido de una
voz hablé con él después de eso viene un
carrito de agua le pregunté si el agua
podía ayudarlo dijo no que tenía que
salir después de eso fue al baño y
perdió el conocimiento
latinoamérica sigue siendo una de las
regiones más golpeadas por el cob y 19
vamos a ver los datos pero es el país
con más muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes y presenta en la región a un
porcentaje de 83 33 chile con 56,48
seguido de brasil con 53 04
méxico con 46 34 y panamá con una
incidencia de 43 79
tenemos también información deportiva y
es que ya sabemos la final de la liga de
campeones- considerada por muchos la
competencia de fútbol a nivel de clubes
más relevante del mundo el bayern múnich
y ganó 3 a 0 al lyon y se enfrentará al
paris saint german en la gran final que
se disputará este domingo 23 de agosto
en el estadio da luz de lisboa el equipo
alemán clasifica así a su undécima final
de esta liga desde esta ciudad
portuguesa natalia ruiz nos contó cómo
el torneo está impactando el turismo tan
necesitado por estos días
la orejona engalana la plaza de rocío y
lisboa es hoy el centro de atención de
los amantes del fútbol aquí se disputa
la fase final de la liga de campeones
por el coronavirus los partidos se
disputan a puerta cerrada los pocos
hinchas de los encuentros por televisión
en bares y restaurantes un sector que
pudo reactivarse vapor en comparación
con los términos en los que no había
deportes y para un bar como el nuestro
ha sido difícil y ha sido un regalo del
juego sin embargo no todos los lisboetas
comparten ese entusiasmo a pesar de ser
un país de fútbol más saben lo que está
en juego el turismo representa el 18 por
ciento del producto interno bruto
portugués no se siente un cambio esta
competición en portugal es como si no
existiera la parte web lo bueno es que
hay menos gente y se camina mejor en la
ciudad lo malo es la parte económica los
turistas hacen falta es un país que vive
esencialmente del turismo por causa del
virus la mitad de los hoteles de la
ciudad aún no tenían clientes hace dos
meses la liga de campeones es entonces
la vitrina ideal para lisboa es un
instrumento fundamental para restablecer
la confianza en este destino
en un mes su virtud y sobre todo para
reestablecer una imagen positiva de
lisboa y de portugal en general la
capital espera en los próximos meses el
regreso contundente de los turistas
extranjeros a menos de que una segunda
ola de kobe 19 dañe los planes
vamos a la portada de nuestro sitio web
france24 puntocom a nuestro artículo de
apertura barack obama habló trump nunca
se ha tomado en serio su trabajo
recuerde que hacemos seguimiento diario
a la convención demócrata que finaliza
esta noche en eeuu
sigue con nosotros llegamos al fin del
informativo esto es france24 buenos días
[Música]